we're gonna begin with this because
we're learning new details about the
remarkable rescue very good me Hana
three people stranded for more than four
days in a West Virginia coal mine hear
that sound that's cheers friends and
family were jubilant during a reunion
last night hours after the group was
found alive inside the mine they had
been missing since Saturday this morning
all three are recovering in the hospital
chip Reed is near the mine in
Whitesville West Virginia
what a story chip good morning
absolutely unbelievable you know there
was an explosion of joy and we heard it
last night when friends and family in
the community center behind me heard the
good news now the medical condition of
the three people who were rescued is
still unclear but they were well enough
to stop by here on their way to the
hospital after 111 hours stranded
underground Kayla Williams Cody Beverly
and Erika Treadway emerged from West
Virginia's Rock House Powell tun mine
Gregg Scarborough is Cody Beverly's
grandfather
this right here community loves one
another you might see us next week
having a difference or whatever because
we're human but when it gets down to
push comes to shove we love whatever
emergency workers raced around the clock
for four days searching deep into the
mine while the amount of oxygen in the
air neared deadly levels entering the
mine which had been inactive for two
years was not easy rescuers had to
remove water at one entrance and
bulldoze a new road outside the other
they used fans to help pump in air four
thousand feet underground in the mind
rescuers say they reached Treadway first
at 6 p.m. then Williams and Beverly 30
minutes later all three walked out on
their own
it's a Christmas blessing that's all
there is to it governor Jim justice
celebrated with the family rescuers
right when they were gathering together
all of them came by me and hit me on the
shoulder said we're going to get him
we're gonna find him immediately a
fourth person who emerged from the mine
on Monday helped guide rescue workers to
the other three one of those rescue
workers tells us this entire mission
could cost as much as a million dollars
and police say the four went into the
mind to steal copper wiring and they
could face criminal charges Liana
but for now everyone is celebrating
Christmas did come early they did and I
know it's bad to go in and steal but I
hope that they'll give them a break I
just think they're out there alive maybe
they've learned a lesson and that that's
over but I love the pure bliss and what
would it chip save the explosion of joy
I love that and you see the smile on the
girl that's right great story